O
LIVE BEHIND A GATE.
JOINING US, FORMER TENNESSEE
CONGRESSMAN FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR HERALD FORD JR.,
THANK YOU CONGRESSMAN.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
POLITICS,HE PERCEPTION IT
SEEPS THATBINING HAS --
IT SEEMS THAT THE
BIN ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN SLOW TO
APPRECIATE THE ISSUE OF
CRIME.
>> HAPPY SUNDAY, THANK YOU.
IHINK THERE IS A
PERCEPTION CHALLENGE THAT MY
PART HAS AROUND THIS ISSUE,
WE'RE FORTUNATE TO HAVE A
POWERFUL VOICE IN ERIC
ERIC ADAMS HERE.
I THINK HIM BEING HERE, AND
PRESIDENT HERE LAST WEEK WAS
A POSITIVE THING FOR HIM
BALLISTICALLY AND
SUBSTANTIVELY, WE SHOULD BE
HONEST ON ABOUT THIS
EXTREMES ON BOTH SIDES INEACH PY
DOMINATE AND ARE GUIDING T
MUCH OF THE CONVERSATION
.
-- ERIC ADAMS' PRESENCE IS A
WELCOME ONE.
YOU LOOK AT DEFUNDING OF
POLICE, BELL REFOR LAWS, IS
NO EXCUSE FOR NOT REFORMING
THE LAWS IN LIGHT OF WHAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH NOW,
DEFUNDING POLICE IS ONE OF
THE DUMBEST AND DUMBEST
POLITICAL REACTION IN LAST
25 YEARS.
SOME SOMEONE UNWILLING TO
CONSIDER, WE SHOULD
PROSECUTE AND USE THE LAWS
BOOKS BUT W HAVE BE
SERIOUS ABOUT THE GHOST GUN
THING, MORE THAN WE ARE.
YO WE SHOULD BE CLEAR ALSO,
DEMOCRATS WILL FACE THE
GREATER POLITICAL LIABILITY
INTO AN ELECTION SEASON
BECAUSE OF THE LISTS OFAS,
AND THINGS THEY -- D.A. AND
THE THING THAT
ADMINISTRATION IS OR NOT
DOE, LAST WEEK WAS A
POSITIVE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION.
BUT THEY HAVE TO ACTS ON IT
SOME NEW YORK PRESS DID NOT
THINK IT WAS A BIG DEAL THE
PRESIDENT COMING, I THINK
THAT "NEW YORK POST," SAID,
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH WAS THEIR
HEADLINE.
AT LEASTT WAS A VISIT.
AND MAYOR ERIC ADAMS IS MANY
WAYS FACE OF DEMOCRAT PARTY
IN HOW WE ADDRESS CRIME.
TREY: CONGRESSMAN.
THE PRESIDENT DID COME, DID
TALK ABOUT MOST GUNS FOR
PEOPLE, THAT IS A GUN NOT
TRACEABLE, DOES NOT HAVE A
SERIAL NUMBER OR MAKES IT
VERY HD TO PROSECUTE IT.
WHEN I WAS IN THE HOUSE ALL
OF THE RAGE WAS GO CLOSING
THE GUN SHOW LOOPHOLE, MY
RESPONSEAS LET'S GET TOUGH
ON GHOST GUNS AND CLOSE THE
GUN SHOW LOOPHOLE.
HOW MANY KILLINGS WOULD THAT
STOP.
WHY WON'T BIDEN GET TGH ON
OGRESSIVE PROSECUTORS OR
THE D.A. IN LOS ANGELES,
THAT IS A MESSAGING STAND
POINT THAT IS MY QUESTION.
>> I DON'T HAVE A GOOD
ANSWER TO THAT, IF IRP IN
WERE IN WHITE HOUSE
WE WOULD HAVE FBI TASK
FORCES, OUT THERE WITH MEN
AND WOMEN ON THE GROUND
HELPING THE POLICE, TRACKING
THESE THINGS AND PROVIDING
THEM BEFORE RESOURCE THEY
NEED.
THAT SHOULD BE HAPPENING.
YOU WANT WE GO BACK AND
FORTH ABOUT THE GUNS AND THE
GHOST GUNS.
ONE THING IS CLEAR, THAT THE
TWO OFFICERS THAT WERE
KILLED HERE OF IN THE WEEK,
THAT WAS A GHOST GUN.
THAT WAS BOUGHT IN PHILLY.
THAT WAS USED BY THAT MAN.
I HOPE THAT THE MESSAGING IN
MY PARTY, IF WE DON'T GET I
RIGHT, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
FAIR WELL IN THISLECTION